On a vu nos parents vivre
d’une manière assez pénible
et on ne voudrait pas, et nos parents
aussi ne voudraient pas
nous voir vivre comme ils ont vécu.
Je m’appelle Auguste Jay,
j’apparais dans la vidéo tournée
à Noël 1966.
Ces jeunes skieurs sont des skieurs
un peu inhabituels.
S’ils sont différents, c’est parce
qu’ils sont ici chez eux.
Ce sont de jeunes paysans
de la montagne.
Ça vous plairait, de faire du ski
toute votre vie ?
- Oh oui !
À l’époque de la vidéo,
j’avais 20 ans.
Aujourd’hui, j’ai 75 ans,
mais ça va !
Depuis le tournage,
j’avais complètement oublié.
C’est ma nièce Aurèle qui m’a montré
la vidéo sur YouTube.
C’est là que les parents d’Auguste
habitent en hiver.
En été, ils habitent une maison
plus moderne.
Mais en hiver, la vieille demeure
est plus pratique
parce que les bêtes y servent
de chauffage central.
On va voir ma maison natale
où a été tournée
la vidéo.
Regardez les arbres !
C’est pas beau, ça ?
Retour en arrière,
mais tout a changé.
Je suis le petit frère d’Auguste,
le dernier de la famille.
Et on a 11 ans d’écart.
Le petit ici,
eh bien c’est moi !
Eh oui ! J’ai changé, hein ?
J’ai pas vieilli, mais...
J’ai grandi, quoi ! Voilà.
Et Auguste est là.
Ça a été tourné ici.
Et au-dessus, il y avait la grange.
Et à côté,
c’était la partie
séjour.
Et à côté,
il y avait...
Les vaches !
Les vaches...
Six ou sept vaches attachées.
Mais... Entrez ! Vous...
Vous prendrez un bout avec nous !
Dans la famille, il y avait
deux parents
la tante et la grand-mère.
A l’époque, c’était presque
une obligation
de prendre en charge les anciens.
Vous avez quel âge, madame?
74 ans.
74 ans ?
Ça fait quelque chose, hein ?
Ça, c’est la tante Louise !
La grand-mère et la tante
dormaient à l’écurie.
Mais il y avait quand même
une cloison
qui séparait les vaches
et la partie habitation.
Et qu’est-ce que vous pensez de la vie
que mènent vos petites-filles,
vos petites-nièces,
pardon, maintenant ?
Je pense qu’elles font bien
d’aller en études.
Vous pensez que c’est mieux ?
Oui, parce que
c’est pas rigolo, ici.
Il y avait deux,
trois lits par chambre
et c’était dispatché
dans plusieurs bâtiments.
Le soir, quand on arrivait
dans la chambre,
il y avait un centimètre
de givre sur les murs.
Et on s’amusait à gratter le mur,
et le givre tombait.
Et on avait les draps
qui étaient humides.
Ah ben le matin, on traînait pas, hein ?
On traînait pas en pyjama,
on s’habillait, on remontait
vite à l’écurie !
Retrouver le chauffage
naturel des vaches.
On est là, vous voyez,
en bonne santé. Et tout.
Le froid conserve !
C’est moi qui prenais
les initiatives.
Mon père était souvent
dans les champs.
Donc, s’il y avait des problèmes
à régler avec mes frères et sœurs,
j’étais là.
Vous êtes en train de dîner, déjà ?
Oui, on casse la croûte, un peu.
On casse la croûte.
Les gens de la montagne
sont accueillants
et ils ouvrent la porte
à tout le monde.
Et ils partagent facilement
le casse-croûte !
C'était le Kiravi (vin de table) !
La consommation de vin,
c’etait inhabituel, chez nous.
Surtout pas pour les enfants.
Mais à l’occasion, là,
mon père
avait sorti les bouteilles !
On vivait
des produits de la ferme :
le beurre, les fromages
de vache, de chèvre
et les viandes.
Chaque année, on tuait à Noël
deux cochons.
Ah, elle fait le beurre !
C’est pas trop fatigant, madame ?
Non, pas trop !
Combien de temps ça dure ?
Peut-être une heure.
Des fois plus !
Là, fallait surtout pas s’arrêter
de battre le beurre,
de faire tourner la baratte
parce que sinon,
il fallait tout recommencer !
Goûtez notre pain et notre tome,
messieurs !
C'est votre pain?
Oui, oui.
Qu’est-ce que vous voulez dire ?
Vous le faites vous-même ?
Oui, bien sûr !
On cultivait
non pas du blé mais du seigle,
qui permettait de faire
notre pain au four du village.
Il y a encore beaucoup de familles,
monsieur, qui font leur pain ici ?
Très peu !
Quand on est tous là,
il faut au moins
deux miches par jour, alors...
Trop de peine pour aller le chercher,
trop loin.
C’est rien, deux miches par jour, mais fallait
monter à pied les chercher à Saint-Martin.
Par une route...
Une route très avalancheuse l'hiver.
Alors il fallait nourrir
tout ce petit monde.
Mais on a jamais
manqué de rien !
La vie d’avant
me paraissait plus simple,
plus concrète.
Je trouve que maintenant,
c’est un peu plus “chacun pour soi”.
Avant, c’était vraiment l’entraide.
Entre agriculteurs, entre gens...
Ne serait-ce qu’avec
les villages d’à côté.
Je sais pas ce que t’en penses ? Mais...
Oui, l’union fait la force !
L’accès au village se faisait
par la ruelle en pente,
ici, là.
C’était le seul moyen
d’accéder au village.
Ça n’a pas été trop dur d’élever
tous ces enfants, monsieur ?
Ben si !
Surtout à la campagne,
c’est assez dur !
On a bien fait comme on a pu !
Surtout maintenant, il faut
les mettre à l’école,
pour qu’ils aient un métier
convenable par la suite.
Si j’étais jeune à leur place,
eh bien je ferais comme eux !
Je suis le dernier à aller
à l’école ici.
Après, j’ai été à Villarenger,
c’est un village à côté.
Jusqu’au certificat d’études.
Et à 16 ans,
je suis parti travailler
à Val Thorens,
dans les remontées mécaniques.
Et toi, pourquoi tu deviens pas
moniteur, Auguste ?
Je fais des études, alors c’est pas
pour faire moniteur.
J’ai vu que je pouvais arriver
à un peu plus,
alors, j’ai pas hésité
à laisser le ski.
Quelle impression ça vous fait
d’avoir un fils à l’université ?
J’ai l’impression, ma foi...
J’ai une bonne impression !
Qu’il puisse continuer ses études
et aller jusqu’au bout.
Je ne pouvais pas
et je ne voulais pas
solliciter mes parents
pour une aide financière.
Parce que je savais qu’il
y avait les frères et sœurs
en bas âge et que
il fallait que je m’assume.
Vous préférez ça plutôt que de le voir
prendre votre succession à la ferme ?
Oh oui !
Je préfère...
un autre métier que...
que nous.
Depuis ma petite enfance
j’ai été toujours obligé
de me surpasser,
de lutter contre tous les problèmes
posés à la vie de la montagne
et, j’ai gardé le goût de l’effort.
Il restait une seule branche que je n’avais pas
envisagée jusqu’à présent,
c’était la médecine.
J’ai pensé que même avec bac philo,
en travaillant, on pouvait y arriver.
Il a fallu que je comble
tous mes retards
en maths, physique, chimie.
Mais
au final, j’ai réussi
du premier coup !
Et toi, tu souhaiterais exercer ton
métier de médecin par ici ?
Ah oui, bien sûr !
J’aurais la neige tout près,
ce serait l’idéal.
J’ai été un médecin de montagne !
J’ai réalisé
un centre médical pluridisciplinaire
qui préfigurait les actuelles maisons de santé,
que j’ai financé tout seul.
J’ai apporté beaucoup de services
réservés aux spécialistes
pour justement répondre aux besoins.
Une fois que j’ai arrêté mon activité
j’ai éprouvé le besoin
d’écrire un livre
"Médecine de proximité
en alerte rouge".
J’ai deux enfants
et j’ai deux petits-enfants.
Qui de toute façon,
ne prendront pas le chemin
de la médecine, apparemment.
Le terme de dire
"mieux avant",
pour moi,
ne correspond à rien.
Il n’y a pas de moment
où on fait les choses mieux qu’avant.
Le message que je pourrais faire passer,
c’est que
rien n’est impossible !